E como você costuma se apresentar para
as pessoas e quando você apresentado
para alguma outra pessoa você já reparou
que geralmente assim oi eu sou a fulana
e faço tal coisa ou quando alguém vai te
apresentar a fala é que a minha amiga
tal pessoa e fala profissão dela eu
nunca acho que eu sou só isso eu sou uma
pessoa tão completa e confusa e faz
tantas outras coisas eu sou mãe eu gosto
de falar japonês eu gosto de rock eu
gosto de chá mate eu nunca pensei falar
a minha profissão quando eu vou me
apresentar porque eu penso que eu sou
muitas coisas além daquilo que eu faço
mas além de tudo o que eu faço eu também
trabalho fazendo faxinas
é aquele trabalho de fazer faxina mesmo
de entrar na casa da pessoa de casar
para ela saúde bem-estar uma economia de
tempo de lavar e esfregar e fazer várias
outras coisas quando eu comecei a
trabalhar eu achava que as pessoas
tinham uma noção diferente com o passar
dos anos dessa profissão mas eu fui
descobrindo que não era bem assim quando
a gente fala do trabalho de limpeza as
pessoas costumam olhar para você pensar
Ah Tadinha essa esse é o seu trabalho e
eu fiquei super preocupada pensando no
porque as coisas eram vistas dessa forma
mas antes eu falar um pouquinho sobre
isso e deixa eu te fazer uma pergunta
nos últimos dias nas últimas horas nas
últimas semanas você precisou de algum
serviço você contratou Algum serviço
você precisou ser atendido por alguém
pensa um pouquinho sobre isso mas
voltando aquilo que eu tava falando eu
já tinha o
é muito grande com essa profissão porque
eu sou neta de uma empregada doméstica a
minha vó trabalhou na casa da mesma
família por mais de 30 anos então a
gente eu via muito que ela era uma
pessoa quase da família mas a minha avó
costumava comer uma comida diferente
oi e ela não comia na cozinha nem na
sala de jantar Claro ela combina na área
de serviço foi meio esquisita não achava
que aquilo fazia muito sentido eu
observei aquilo por muitos anos mas
nunca questionava nem perguntava para
ela nem Claro para família nem para
ninguém eu só observava aquela situação
os anos foram se passando eu acompanhei
outras pessoas Tinha pessoas que
trabalhavam na minha casa eu conhecia
outras pessoas nas Casas dos meus amigos
que faziam esse trabalho mas eu entendi
a que existia uma distância entre quem
contratava o serviço e quem executava
mas eu não entendi o porquê até que
trinta e tantos anos depois eu comecei a
fazer esse trabalho e eu fui percebendo
não só a distância mas a forma como ele
é visto pelas pessoas
bom então Lembra que eu falei que as
pessoas falavam puxa Tadinha ela
trabalha fazendo faxinas parece que a
faxina é aquilo que sobrou eu não tive
outra opção eu não pude escolher Mas
nenhum momento ninguém nunca perguntou
se eu estava feliz ou se eu ganhava bem
você tava tudo bem com a minha escolha
porque fazer faxinas no final das contas
se tornou a minha escolha
e quando eu faço o meu trabalho eu
entendo o potencial que eu tenho de
transformar a vida da pessoa que eu tô
entrando na casa porque essa pessoa tá
passando por uma transformação ela sai
vai trabalhar deixa a casa de um jeito
quando ela volta tá de outro e eu sei
que eu fui o agente dessa transformação
então quando alguém olha e pensa assim
ela não faz nada ela não é nada eu fico
pensando que as transformações acontecem
como sozinha mas já que é assim a forma
que as pessoas pensam eu tento deixar
desse jeito
o e voltava para casa pensando
Ah tá Se eu deixar desse jeito não vai
dar certo então no começo da minha
profissão eu precisava encontrar uma
forma de entrar na casa das pessoas
porque Pensa bem é estranho você chamar
alguém que você nunca viu para dividir a
sua intimidade para ver as suas coisas
para ver a sua sujeira então imaginei
que eu precisava ter uma forma de trazer
essa pessoa para perto de mim e que a
gente fosse próximas de alguma forma sim
começar pela proximidade está vendo ali
a sujeira dela
e eu fiz um anúncio nas redes sociais
que viralizou mas honestamente eu não
estava planejando nada daquilo eu fiz um
anúncio muito simples para expressar
quem eu era e dizer que é aquele
trabalho era o trabalho que me fazia
feliz e era forma que eu tinha
encontrado que sustentar minha família
e quando eu percebi que o post tinha
visualizado e as pessoas estavam
compartilhando e vende rindo porque eu
usei referência da cultura pop que é uma
coisa muito presente para mim muito
importante tenho várias tatuagens que
tem referência de Cultura pop Então eu
queria que as pessoas soubessem quem eu
era soubessem como eu pensava do que eu
gostava então esses cartazes de Filmes
séries bandas de rock que eu gosto
transformados em anúncios de faxina
trouxe muita gente para perto de mim
Claro bombar nas redes sociais alguma
coisa porque like é legal mas não paga a
conta então isso virou cliente e essas
pessoas se tornaram meus clientes e meus
amigos eu percebi que eu tinha um espaço
muito grande eu podia usar esse espaço
para falar outras coisas que não fossem
só o meu anúncio e criei uma página onde
a dividir com as pessoas o dia-a-dia do
meu trabalho e contava com crônicas
fazer a playlists
e isso foi fazendo um foi trazendo um
espaço de reflexão e discussão de um
trabalho que ninguém falava depois eu
descobri que eu fui a primeira faxineira
a produzir conteúdo para as redes
sociais hoje eu faxina boa conversa com
centenas de milhares de pessoas e isso
fez com que recebesse diversas mensagens
de diversos lugares de todo o mundo e
certa vez eu recebi uma mensagem que
dizia assim a minha família não tem
consideração por mim porque ela eles
dizem que eu não dei certo então ele
sentem vergonha por causa do meu
trabalho mas quando eu vejo você eu
entendo que eu tenho um lugar no mundo e
que esse lugar vem que a minha profissão
não define quem eu sou eu sou muito
orgulhosa De quem eu sou e do que eu
faço muito obrigada foi uma vez que eu
percebi que é aquilo é aquilo que eu
queria fazer eu queria conversar com
essas pessoas e fazer com que elas
entendessem a importância do trabalho
dela
o e recentemente eu recebi uma mensagem
de uma criança e essa criança disse que
ele não se importava muito com quem
estava ali ao redor E principalmente na
escola ele tinha uma forma de tratar a
mulher que limpa a cantina da escola que
era uma forma muito ríspida e ele jogava
deixava o resto do lanche e falava ela
tá aqui para isso e de repente ele disse
que viu os meus conteúdos na internet e
que não trata mais ela assim e perguntou
qual era o nome dela uma coisa que
acontece muito a gente trabalha com
limpeza é que a gente perde a identidade
a gente vira a tia da limpeza não tem
nome não tem preferência não tem
conhecimento você não é nada você pega
um elevador super escondido que o
elevador de serviço você não interage
com essas pessoas na verdade elas nem se
importam muito com o que você tá fazendo
elas só querem o serviço pronto e quando
eu passei a colocar ali uma cara uma
o e uma história nessa profissão outras
pessoas apareceram Isso mudou a forma
como o trabalho não só o trabalho
doméstico é feito mas a prestação de
serviços lembra que eu perguntei se você
tinha usado Algum serviço Ultimamente eu
tenho certeza que você usou e todas
essas pessoas elas são muito importantes
porque são elas que fazem o que você
tenha o conforto que você tem que você
tem os acessos que você tem então todas
essas pessoas ela não tem um diploma ela
não tem o crachá ela não tem o NBA Mas
ela tá fazendo uma coisa muito
importante isso sempre precisa ser
deixado Claro e foi nesse momento que eu
percebi que a conteúdo que eu produzia
nas redes sociais ele tinha até mesmo
caráter educacional
Oi e aí eu pensei puxa vida
Olá eu sou tantas coisas que até um
pouco de Educadora eu sou E aí eu tinha
já feito algumas palestras eu escrevi um
livro e eu fiz várias outras coisas
então no momento em que eu percebi esse
potencial óbvio que a síndrome de a
impostora me pegou eu vivia pensando no
Será que eu tô fazendo as coisas certas
Será que eu mereço tá aqui será que tudo
isso que tá acontecendo é real e a gente
descobre nesse momento uma coragem que a
gente talvez não soubesse que a gente
tem então a gente consegue a partir de
pequenos movimentos de pequenas coisas e
de pequenas atitudes provocar grandes
transformações e assim eu fui
descobrindo que além de faxineira além
de criadora de conteúdo além de mãe além
de uma pessoa que adora falar japonês Eu
também era uma Educadora Eu também
conseguia tocar o coração das pessoas e
fazer diversas outras coisas então o que
eu percebo é que não importa o que é que
você faz importa
se você faz muito obrigada
[Aplausos]